hi I'm Victoria I'm Alexa Raley and this
week we're gonna try to be zero waste
[Music]
well I decided to do this challenge
because I'm a urban and environmental
sustainability major and I've always
been like environmentally conscious but
as that major in like taking other
classes I felt like I could be doing
more for the environment and I really
wanted to like push myself to that like
extra Drive would be like super
environmentally conscious I'm just
really scared of like what's going on
with the environment right now every
time I see things like in the media
about the environment in the state of it
it really scares me so I feel like if I
can contribute in any way like it'll
make me feel at least a little bit
better and like I'm you're doing my part
yeah I was already curious especially in
the city like how packaging works and
what kind of food you can eat on like a
no waste diet I guess because most
things come in packaging and we know
that plastic bags are everywhere in New
York City and there's trash all over the
sidewalk and I just want to see like how
much one person can do with no waste I
became aware of the zero waste lifestyle
through like YouTube videos and I
remember seeing this one woman who
literally just has a mason jar for trash
for like two years this is going to be
my little handy dandy trash jar my goal
is to keep the trash all in this one jar
for the whole week so I guess we'll see
if I'm able to meet that goal it is the
first morning day 1 trash so far I've
got two tags in here from articles of
clothing that I divide for work there
are a lot of things I'd only take like
an extra few seconds I really enjoy
composting actually I felt like the
garbage was cleaner in your house other
than having that big trash bag I just
started my compost I'm actually really
proud of it so here is what it looks
like I filled it about a little less
than halfway with some soil oh I'm just
going to put the lid on top I cut some
holes in it but yeah this is where
my little DIY composter is going to live
I did a mock run of going grocery
shopping at Whole Foods just to see what
they had because it was the closest
store that I knew sold in bulk and it
was good but it was really expensive and
a lot of the stuff that I needed came
and plastic packaging especially like
meats and stuff I know maybe I shouldn't
be eating me if we're going like
completely there always maybe I like to
try that the problem for me is that it's
hard to find any protein besides peanut
butter or almond butter and I'm a big
protein person most of my food is
protein I eat a lot of chicken I think
that the grocery part for me at least
was a little much
because I had to drive like 50 minutes
because that's the closest bookstore to
me I just cut out of the bulk item at
the grocery store and I maybe got like
10 ish things maybe a little bit more
and it was literally $60 I kind of feel
like crying at the amount I just spent
in there and that's not even going to be
like enough for a week so needless to
say this zero waste lifestyle like
grocery wise is extremely expensive I
also feel like it's a bit easier in the
cities rather than like the country or
like more suburban areas because I feel
like the cities are like the first place
where there's like more bulk stores that
are accessible I have been googling
things like grocery stores and stuff
like that I did find a delivery service
for zero waste so I think I'm actually
just gonna check that out instead I'm
about to order hold on it's going to be
about 60 ish dollars that is another
reason why it's not that accessible to
people is because of the price but
hopefully that'll get better it'll get
more accessible but I'm excited for it
to be delivered so they came to my door
and they came in these two vibes so
let's see this is so cute I'm living
good morning it is day two of the zero
waste challenge I decided I'm going to
make some oatmeal today I feel like it's
impossible to go all in and create no
waste at all but I feel like if you can
adapt some of the things of zero waste
yeah then you're at least contributing
and trying to make a difference in
helping in some way this is kind of what
I was feeling a little weird about
because I didn't know if I had to like
kind of start from scratch and buy
everything over again and get rid of all
this plastic stuff but the more articles
and the more things that I read said
that you should use all of your existing
products up because just throwing
everything away you're not using them
kind of goes against the zero-waste
motto I think even trying is important
like just adapting certain things like
it's probably easy to buy a bamboo
toothbrush it feels different in your
mouth in a normal toothbrush so but
we're gonna review together I just feel
like a baby toothbrush I'm scared to
like ask the people at restaurants like
hey can I put this in my own container
because I watched a lot of videos with
people going to like fast food places or
to regular restaurants and they're like
what today I work all day long and
to attempt to get lunch that is zero
waste I had planned to something to go
and so I plan to go to just salad at
that place you can buy a reuse of a bowl
for just a dollar and I was like sweet
I'm gonna use that and at the end the
girl who made it was like you can't use
that fold this visit you have to wash it
out and I was like it makes sense okay
so I got it in this now I have to carry
this and this and this around with me oh
I do not good morning in a stay three of
these here waste challenge I just got
back from the party I decided to stay
the night and I actually am really proud
of myself because I barely need any
waste I pretty much got like all of my
friends thinking about zero waste which
is really cool so they were all like oh
my gosh like you're using reusable
Tupperware and like your own silverware
like that's actually kind of cool I love
it
okay I'm hiding in the corner making
this video at work so here's my question
for you cuz I don't really know
I have to give plastic straws to my
customers I have to throw out napkins
that count is my trash because technique
me up obligated to do it I don't know
but now that I'm doing the challenge I
feel really bad about doing it I don't
know what it is about this challenge but
I also think this is like a health
challenge in a way because I have been
feeling a healthier because I just feel
like I might be because much junk food
and takeout and things like that I've
been drinking a lot of water and let me
be honest I don't drink water I don't
like water
hello just go ahead they'll probably
edit it out I don't know I'm just
feeling good about the stuff that I'm
eating this week and I hope that these
trends stay it's Monday so it's day no
stay for and I have the best boyfriend
in the world and he bought me edible
arrangements which is amazing but now
I've got some trash on me I have a
confession to make my roommate and I got
the munchies last night a little bit and
so we like a ran to the kitchen we were
all excited and I look there was a whole
bag of snickerdoodle
Thanks it's so much waste baking those
cookies so you've got flyer the
packaging was this ear plastic bag
though that's going in my jar we've got
I think of something to keep it cold the
butter is wrapped in a weird plastic
thing that's going in my jar another
flyer cinnamon sugar that was in its own
separate plastic bag so that was a third
thing going in my jars and then every
piece of chocolate comes in this I
craved
I just wanted them so I don't was one
but they were good can't recycle this
and I can't recycle the little pods that
each fruit comes in so that's going
straight into my trash bottle so now
that I did that dirty deed I am more
conscious I mean like listen
everything's gonna be perfect
zero waste Victoria is happening right
damn now I wasn't supposed to create any
trash but for starting and for not
really knowing much this is not that
much trash mostly with the rest of
Eclipse me all right you all so listen
up I just got off work I'm going to the
movies right now and the game plan is
I'm gonna get my drink
my tiny a water bottle because I need to
get something when I see this movie or
else it just won't be like my
traditional movie theater experience and
hopefully all goes well did you feel any
way they could have feedback or any like
I ruling yeah I did when I went out to
eat at one time me and my friend wanted
to make sure that the straws shot their
way back to the kitchen so when she
brought them we looked at her and we
said hey like could you take these back
we don't need them
and I literally was like looking at the
guys behind us and I get the table and
they literally went like and just looked
so confused like literally like we had
murdered someone I'm not
they were just laughing and sort of like
making fun of it I don't care that
people are making fun of me or people
think I'm stupid or whatever but it's
like what's so weird about that like I
don't think that that's that weird yeah
to think that people feel that way is
like I don't know what made me kind of
upset my movie mission was a success I
just went up and I used my water bottle
and yeah I got my slushie great
experience zero waste love it update on
the sponge situation I want to show you
something I will never go back to a
sponge again after using this
biodegradable cloth because Rochdale
that actually it was so much better than
a sponge have you guys ever used them I
you can wipe peanut butter off and then
it wipes right off the sponge as soon as
you put it under water it's amazing
watch this ready
take off your peanut butter like magic
is my new baby and I can do dishes
without worrying about the sponge
getting disgusting every single time
today is the second to last day of each
challenge I actually just got back from
the thrift store
I love thrifting and it's obviously
really good and sustainable for the
environment since you are buying
secondhand clothes
I am on my way to a sushi place
downstairs but I brought a container and
I'm going to ask for my sushi to be put
over here today my goal is
having
zero waste day brought my salad bowl for
lunch so I can finally used
and then I
ceramic thermos or whatever that my
roommate gave me I'm gonna see if
Starbucks will let me use this instead I
have no idea what their policies are but
hopefully it'll work out so I actually
did get a pair of jeans but this tag
came on so this is gonna have to go into
the trash arm but they did it they put
my two rolls in my little container this
is the only problem with it because the
soy sauce but I reuse these for salad
dressing so it's not going to waste
which is awesome when I asked for the
solution in my container they did it but
then went with the ginger and the wasabi
uh they put the little green
granddaughter decoration
and there's things like you can't help
even when you ask for absolutely no way
I'm just doing their jobs nothing yeah
but like the old frustrating it's yeah
right yeah so basically I guess it sure
does tell me how the challenge what it
was good it was definitely easier in
some ways than I thought it would be but
it was also more difficult in ways that
I didn't think it would be it definitely
was the little things I think I
mentioned that at the beginning of the
week like I was nervous about all the
little tiny like tags and stuff and I
have quite a few of those it's the final
day of the challenge I use a little more
trash yesterday I used a cotton ball to
take off my makeup it was the first time
I wore makeup all week I really never
wear makeup and I tried scrubbing as
much of it off as I could in the shower
and it just wasn't working so I had to
use a cotton ball cuz it's just gross
and bacterial and it's just not good I
didn't want dental floss on in there I
don't know
applause in here yeah and I feel like
there's a lot of things that like you
have to do that are out of control with
the tags like you don't put them on the
clothes but like they're there and like
if you need to buy or you have to buy it
that's just part of like the trashing
you're creating okay so I'm at the train
station and instead of buying my ticket
on the machine I decided to buy it on
the app to save the unnecessary paper
because when you buy a train ticket you
get actual ticket and then a receipt and
my mom is with me so he would have had
four pieces of paper instead we decided
to book round-trip on the after both of
us so saving paper I would say yeah the
trash that I saved was definitely less
than I expected I felt like a lot of
things were gonna compile together and I
was this was like gonna be filled to the
brim I have to bring like two or three
of these in but honestly just to be
conscious about it you realize that the
stuff that you usually buy you don't
need to and so the amount of trash is
actually a lot less than you think and
it really is like the little things yeah
I was proud of the amount that I had
saved and put into their star because it
really shows me that it's like not that
hard to do I feel like as for the
receipts and some of the little like
plastic things that clothing or other
items come on like nothing it's not my
fault but it was kind of like out of my
control obviously like this little
wrapper from my chicken nuggets was but
I really wanted chicken nuggets
so like the cookies girl exactly yeah I
definitely feel like I don't have as
much as I thought which is really cool
and it makes me feel like proud my god
oh yeah yeah I may though but it's it's
cool yeah I feel like I already did a
lot of meal prepping for myself so I
don't have many like food wrappers in
here but like there are a lot of things
that are out of my control like I
plastic the doctor's office cuz yeah
they put the thing on mm-hmm
they put it in this plastic bag and I
could've just thrown it out there but
this is my trash because I've used it so
this is going in my bottle of shame my
advice to anyone that wants to try a
zero-waste would definitely be to do
your research and find resources in your
area that work for you and that are
close to you my advice would be to not
let accessibility stop you from trying
to be zero waste there are all these
little things that you can do by like
bringing your own bottles to Starbucks
or just bringing your Tupperware out to
eat don't be afraid to challenge
yourself and don't be afraid to just try
new things the little things do count
like if you can do the grocery haul and
you can't do you know not buying a
specific thing like if you need meat for
some reason bringing a cup and bringing
Tupperware and meal prepping just a
little bit like does add up and it does
really count if you can't do the whole
lifestyle and I also want to say do your
research it helps a lot and it takes
maybe 30 minutes of your time
bake mourn that's what I did this week I
was just craving sugar and I baked a lot
add these little silicon cupcake liners
so if you're like baking get those
because they were helpful with my
cupcakes no waste cupcakes cupcakes
always kind of way to cover your eyes oh
my gosh trademark copyright in that's my
cake up don't update shop